-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Great to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
During yesterday's hearing,
ex-Trump White House aide
Cassidy Hutchinson testified
that former President Trump
threw plates of food
on several occasions
when he was angry.
Never his, of course.
[ As Trump ]
Eric, give me your plate.
[ Laughter ]
After the House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
showed handwritten notes
from ex-Trump aide
Cassidy Hutchinson
during yesterday's hearing,
former President Trump
attacked Hutchinson
on his Truth social platform
and said,
"Bad handwriting,
that of a Whacko?"
Hers?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yours looks like the results
of a lie detector test.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Sir, can you name
all the state capitals?"
[ As Trump ]
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Fox News host Brian Kilmeade
criticized former
President Trump
and said that he became unhinged
following the 2020 election.
You know what that means --
the Fox & Friends
are going
to need a longer couch.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
host Brian Kilmeade said
that former President Trump
became unhinged
following the 2020 election,
and added,
"I believe from the time when
the election results came in
until January 6th
is the worst moment
of Donald Trump's
political career."
And it's never a good sign
when your worst moment lasted
three months.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
political strategists believe
that the upcoming
presidential primary
may push Republican candidates
to move further to the right
on abortion.
How much further can they go...?
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
announced this week
that ratproof trash cans will be
installed around the city,
transforming New York
from a city full of rats
to a city full of angry,
starving rats.
[ Laughter ]
In a new book, Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas said
that Americans seem
to have lost interest
in constitutional matters,
and added,
"people tend to be more
interested in their iPhones
than their Constitution."
Well, I think that's because
the people who update the iPhone
know what they're doing.
[ Laughter ]
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
criticized "Sesame Street"
on Twitter yesterday
after Elmo promoted coronavirus
vaccines for young children.
He criticized
"Sesame Street" again?
Dude! If you don't like
the show, stop watching it.
[ Laughter ]
You sound like me talking
about "Ozark."
"They would've been killed
so many times, by now."
[ Laughter ]
Colorado Representative
Lauren Boebert yesterday
won her Republican primary,
easily defeating her opponent --
reality.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
Pinterest announced yesterday
that the company's CEO will be
stepping down.
The announcement was made
on an adorable throw pillow.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody!